Palestine it is the homeland of
Palestinians but you won't find it on a
map where exactly is Palestine to answer
that we need to go back to 1917
that's when British forces captured an
Arab majority region known as Palestine
from the Ottoman Empire they wrote the
ball for Declaration which encouraged
persecuted European Jews to join the
Jewish minority already living there by
1947 the United Nations had to post a
plan for both a Jewish state and an Arab
Palestinian state but that never
happened
war between Arabs and Jews broke out and
by 1948 the British had left and the
State of Israel was created Palestinians
call the event the neckla which means
catastrophe more than 700,000
Palestinians became refugees the new
country of Israel included more land and
was initially proposed by the UN but no
Arab Palestinian state was created
Palestinians were relegated to the West
Bank Gaza and beyond then in 1967 about
300,000 Palestinians fled territories
taken by Israel in a war with
neighboring countries nearly 400
Palestinian villages were destroyed
since then Palestinian land keeps
disappearing on the map Israel continues
to build settlements in the West Bank in
a separation while that pushes out even
more Palestinians today the State of
Israel now makes up a majority of what
was once historical Palestine